-Where is he?
Yo! Come on, my man!
-What's up? How are you?
-I'm great.
Everything's great.
I can't complain.
Knock on wood.
It's like we're all healthy,
together.
Dude, are you missing L.A.
-A little bit, but, like, we'r
in a very nice place right now
and it's just like
we're playing activities.
We're acting
like we're kids again.
We've been playing Wiffle Ball
or Mario Kart.
-Wiffle Ball. Wiffle Ball is
a thing right now.
Oh, my God.
-Dude, what's your pitch?
I can throw a mean curveball
-See, we're learning.
We're still learning.
-I'm getting there.
Some days, I'm on point.
-There's a game that people ar
playing on the Internet.
It's called like
#CouplesChallenge,
but I thought it'd be fun
if we did, like,
a brother version of it where,
basically, I ask you questions
and you both have
your eyes closed,
and all you do is point to
either yourself or the brother
and if you both point
to the same person,
you'll get one point.
And never open your eyes.
-Okay, you'll tell us at the end
how we did?
I will tell you at the end how
many points you guys have gotten
if you're legit bros.
Alright, are you ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Let's do it.
-Here we go.
Close your eyes.
Who spends more time
on Instagram?
Who's better at Wiffle Ball?
Who has stronger
Neil Diamond vibes?
[ Laughter ]
I'll tell you about that later
Who is more likely to get in a
political fight on social media?
Who is more fun during
a sleep-over?
[ Laughs ]
Guys, I'm not kidding!
Open your eyes.
5 out of 5 on that one.
-Wow!
-Alright!
A lot of them are both.
A lot of them -- I mean, I can
go toe-to-toe on social media.
-Who has stronger
Neil Diamond vibes?
-[ Laughs ]
That's because
last time Scott was on,
we asked him a question.
He told me a story
that's very funny to me.
I don't have to bring it up.
I can just hold it
over your head forever.
-This -- I'm not --
-Here's the last round.
These are five questions.
You get this, we'll know
that you guys are true bros.
Alright, eyes closed.
Who's more likely
to casually bring up
how many push-ups they can do?
Who got in more trouble
in school?
Ooh.
[ Laughs ]
Who's gone the longest without
showering during quarantine?
Before quarantine, who was the
most likely to have gone a wee
without showering --
before quarantine?
-[ Laughs ] Ohh.
-I mean --
You pointed at me?
-Last -- [ Laughs ]
Last one.
Last question.
And for this one,
don't point with your finger
point with your nose.
Who smells worse right now
-[ Laughs ]
-I finally showered
after a week, so...
-Alright, that was a joke
right there.
You guys, we rounded it up
You guys are officially bros
-Alright.
-We disagree on everything
-You passed the bro challenge.
Man, I love seeing you guys.
I love seeing you again.
We'll hopefully get to see eac
other in person soon.
That includes you, Scott.
Whenever.
It's an open invitation, please.
-Alright, I'm in.
-Come back, and let's play
Chris, you rock, buddy.
Bye, guys. Be safe.
Thank you.